And we are now ready to prove Euler's
theorem, that will
help us to find paths visiting every
edge in the graph exactly once.
Actually, we will be focusing on the
Eulerian Cycle problem.
Find a cycle that visits every edge in the
graph, because Euler was interested in
a walk in Kernigsberg that starts and
ends at the same place.
There is cosmetic, very small differences,
between finding Eulerian cycles and
Eulerian paths.
As soon as we learn how to find cycles,
we will learn how to find paths, and vice
versa.
Let us start from a question.
Does this graph have an Eulerian cycle?
Or, in other words, is this graph
Eulerian?
Of course not, because there is no way out
of the red node.
What about this graph?
It's also non Eulerian because there's no
way in, into the the red node.
And what about this graph?
We need to look a little bit more closer
but we will, immediately find
a red node here for which there is one
incoming and two outgoing edges.
Which means that this graph cannot
possibly be Eulerian,
because in every Eulerian cycle, the
number of times we enter into
a node equals to the number of times we
leave the node.
And therefore, the number of incoming
edges in every node should
be equal to the number of outgoing edges
from every node.
We call a graph balanced if, in-degree of
every node, equal to its out-degree.
Or in other words, the number
of incoming edges to every node equals the
number of outgoing edges.
Is this graph balanced?
Of course, we can see that for every
node there are two incoming and two
outgoing edges.
But, it doesn't help us yet to figure out
whether there is an Eulerian cycle in this
graph.
And now, we are ready to present Euler's
theorem.
We already saw that every Eulerian graph
is balanced.
So this graph has a chance to be Eulerian.
Euler proved that every balanced graph is
Eulerian, of course balanced
and strongly connected because if graph
is disconnected there's no way to find.
Let's prove this theorem.
And to prove the theorem, we need to
recruit an ant, and let it randomly walk
through the graph, of
course with the condition that the ant
cannot visit the same edge twice.
Let's start.
If ant was a genius, then he would simply
walk along the graph.
As I show here, visited all edges of the
graph, and finally,
returned back.
But an average ant, wouldn't be that
lucky, and it would start travelling
through the graph, start walking, and
eventually, it would get stuck.
Let's stop for a second and think.
But to what node this ant can possibly get
stuck?
Can it get stuck in the middle of the
graph?
Presumably not,
because our graph is balanced, and
therefore every time the ant is
entering into a node, there should be a
way out of the node.
This condition holds for all nodes in the
graph, except for one.
Which one?
Of course, it's the starting node of the
ant, because in
the starting node, the ant has already
used the first outgoing edge,
so it may arrive in this node and there
will be no out going edge left.
And therefore what we learn that the ant
can
only get stuck at the node where it
starts.
What can we do?
Afterwards the ant failed to construct the
Eulerian Cycle, because it did not visit.
all edges of the graph.
But maybe,
just maybe, we can start at a different
node in the green cycle.
Let's start at a different node in the
green cycle.
Also it's not clear what differences does
it make but why shouldn't we try to start
in a node in the cycle where there is still
unexplored edges.
For example, at this node in the cycle,
there are still unexplored edges
left, so let's force that to start here,
at this node, and in the beginning, let's
tell them, first follow the same cycle that
you constructed in the previous step.
So the ant starts walwking along the green
cycle.
The ant absolutely doesn't understand why he
has to
do this kind of thing along the cycle
that he already constructed but finally he
arrives to the initial
node and now he realizes that actually now
he can continue walking.
Because the rest still unexplored edges
from this ?
node.
Then continues walking, continues walking,
continues walking, and finally got stuck.
And of course it got stuck in the same
node where it started.
What you should do today,
afterwards?
Then afterwards, we should start at
another node with the still unexplored
edges.
Where is this node?
Can be, well, this is the node, with still
unexplored edges.
The ant first will be ordered to traverse
the cycle that has been already
constructed, there's
this green blue cycle, and then starts,
continue, continue, continue, the ant is not
happy but
it's okay.
Continue and finally, it arrives to the
initial node, but now the
ant realizes that  the instructions
are not stupid because there is a possibility
to explore it further, and we continue,
continue, continue, and finally, the ant
constructed the cycle that we wanted, that
visits every edge of the graph exactly
once.
Not only ant constructed the cycle, we
actually just
came up with this algorithm for doing this
and this
should accord describe our instructions to
the ant, and you can
implement it and get real result in an
efficient algorithm.
And if we would now put an ant
to search de Bruijn graphs constructed for
universal string,
in this case just in three iterations, it
will
construct Eulerian cycle, and therefore
construct a universal string.
You can check that you will, can, be able
to derive universal string from the cycle.